i
[Música]
ah
la canciller alemana angela merkel
enfrenta unos momentos más difíciles en
su último periodo al frente de alemania
cuando faltan apenas cinco meses para
que le realicen las elecciones federales
de septiembre que determinarán quién
será su sucesor al frente de alemania el
manejo de la pandemia de parte de las
autoridades ha sido fuertemente
criticado en las últimas semanas en
particular por las disputas que ha
habido entre la cancillería el gobierno
federal por un lado y por el otro los
líderes de las 16 regiones de alemania
que en últimas son los encargados de
poner en práctica las medidas contra el
coronavirus ha sido muy difícil
encontrar consensos en alemania y esto
ha dado lugar a un popurrí de medidas
contra el coronavirus ya mucha confusión
entre la población y eso también se ha
visto reflejado en la imagen de los
políticos sangre a merkel sigue siendo
la política con los niveles de
favorabilidad más altos pero éstos se
han visto afectados en comparación con
los últimos meses la mayoría de los
alemanes asegura que no está satisfecho
con el manejo de la pandemia de parte de
las autoridades esto genera preguntas no
solamente sobre el impacto que pueden
tener estas cifras en las elecciones
federales de septiembre sino también en
el impacto que puedan tener sobre el
legado que deje la canciller alemana
angela mente
[Música]
la popularidad del presidente del
gobierno español pedro sánchez no se ve
afectada por la pandemia según las
últimas encuestas su partido ganaría
ahora mismo en las elecciones el psoe
obtendría más de 30% en estimación de
voto muy por delante del conservador
partido popular pero hay una paradoja no
significa que los españoles aprueben su
trabajo le dan una mala nota a pedro
sánchez un 4.3 sobre 10 a pesar de la
pandemia esa valoración es estable es la
misma que cuando fue investido
presidente del gobierno en enero pasado
también es la mejor nota entre todos los
líderes de partidos políticos españoles
si se mantiene esa popularidad es porque
hay una desconfianza general en los
políticos en españa pedro sánchez
aparece como el menos malo también
significa que su comunicación de crisis
que consiste en salir más en los medios
ha funcionado su popularidad podría
conocer un repunte este verano sí como
el año pasado remite la pandemia
[Música]
con la firma del break si la imagen del
primer ministro boris johnson mejoró
pero ésta resultó nuevamente impactada
por el manejo del gobierno de los
primeros meses de la pandemia se le
cuestiona especialmente que el país haya
alcanzado la triste cifra de más de
100.000 muertos por covite 19 y se le
cuestiona especialmente que no haya
adoptado decretado en los primeros días
de marzo de 2020 cuando el kobe 19 se
estaba propagando rápidamente por europa
el primer confinamiento en este país
pero lo cierto es que tras más de un año
de pandemia de 3 confinamientos y la
campaña de vacunación más exitosa de
europa donde aquí en el reino unido se
ha vacunado más del 60% de la población
adulta
la imagen de boris johnson sigue
mejorando pero no es así en todas las
naciones de la unión en todas las
naciones del reino unido- dado que los
gobiernos regionales de escocia de gales
y de irlanda del norte han adoptado un
manejo local de esta pandemia del cobi
[Música]